c'est une course contre la montre
un travail de 24 heures pour que tout
soit envoyé à temps pour patricia
l'important c'est d'être méthodique faut
faire donc c'est prendre de grandes
feuilles et que donc les petits
bulletins et ensuite donc de les mettre
dans l'enveloppent et dans le carton est
déterminés on redemande à nos cartons la
mise sous pli des professions de foi des
candidats nécessite de la concentration
malgré la chaleur
oui oui très important si on veut être
efficace faut s'hydrater chaque
enveloppe doit avoir le même contenu un
travail en binôme répétitif mais utile
on change de poste foot les deux de
manière à pas
faire tout en comptant la même chose ça
fait plaisir en tout cas travailler pour
pour clavier les élections parce que je
pense que c'est important l'année sous
pli le début de la campagne
électorale vous voyez bien donc il faut
bien des gens qui le fasse et moi je
suis ravi
260 personnes se sont portées
volontaires parmi elles des agents de la
ville ou de la préfecture de côte-d'or
qu'il a fallu former on leur a donné des
conseils de méthode ensuite les agences
sont rémunérées au nombre d' enveloppe
qui vont effectuer donc s'ils sont très
efficaces ils auront voilà une bonne une
bonne rémunération en plus des cinq
circonscriptions de côte-d'or tout le
matériel électoral pour les bureaux de
vote dès 700 communes doit être préparée
enveloppe bulletins de vote des éléments
essentiels à la bonne tenue du scrutin
que nous avons une semaine entre le
premier vous le savez le deuxième tour
des législatives ces cours sur les
présidentielles le délai plus long il y
avait quinze jours entre les deux tours
donc ça suppose que la mécanique soit
bien réglée plus de 360 milles enveloppe
vont être envoyés soit le nombre
d'électeurs de côte-d'or la distribution
par la poste doit commencer dès demain
jusqu'au samedi 18 juin veille du second
tour